from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills bloomberg opinion writer frank
berry is driving in an rv with his wife
laurel across the country from new york
city
all the way to san francisco and his
arrival date is
election day he's going to be updating
us along the journey and telling us what
he learns about
voters what's important to people and
how local officials are responding to
everything going on in our country right
now so joining us for an update is frank
barry frank how are you doing hi madison
doing great
we uh we are we've made it to ohio and
we survived driving through
downtown newark and philadelphia and
across pennsylvania and over the
allegheny mountains so
so far so good well thank you for making
time to check in with
us uh before we talk about what's next
for you and what you've experienced so
far
i want to give viewers a look into how
your journey started so let's take a
look at this video real quick
hi i'm frank barry i'm a writer at
bloomberg opinion and i'll be taking
this rv across the country on a drive
from new york to san francisco following
the lincoln highway
the country's in turmoil and it seems
like the right time to go out on the
road
and to capture the country in this
moment but also to seek out those things
that still
bind us together and that hopefully will
pull us through
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the lincoln highway was america's oldest
transcontinental route that runs from
new york to san francisco
and along the way it hits a number of
major cities but it also hits
tons of small towns little places that
most people have never been to
and we're going to be speaking with
people all along the route
and what's business like these days
my wife laurel and i are going to leave
from the heart of the city in times
square
and the journey will end in san
francisco for us but we hope that it
will also point the way forward
at a time when the country is seemingly
more divided than it's been in
generations it's set by multiple crises
between covet racial injustices and an
economic recession
that could be as deep as any we've felt
in many many decades
this is very much a journey of discovery
it's a quest we're not
leaving with all the answers we're not
leaving to do all the talking
we hope to get a feel for what the
country is going through right now
and to take a little bit of a portrait
of america
during this time and so i'll be posting
a weekly update
and if you're interested please post any
comments you have any questions
and i hope you'll come along for the
[Music]
journey
[Music]
frank i love that line it's a quest uh
so i i will ask you what has request
been like so far the quest has been
great and it's a it's a quest for a
discovery
uh and to learn and to ask questions and
to meet people where they are
uh and to try to leave as many
preconceived notions and ideas behind
uh so i've had some really terrific
conversations with with people along the
way
and i know you've done a lot of work
scheduling some amazing
interviews and conversations for your
column that's running alongside this uh
can you
take me into some of those conversations
what have been some of the big learnings
you've had so
far from those uh conversations sure
well my first conversation
was really where the lincoln highway
started just outside of manhattan and
jersey city and i spoke with mayor steve
phillip
who's got a real interesting story he
had a job at goldman sachs coming out of
graduate school
and quit after 9 11 to join the marines
and serve the country
and we met actually on 9 11 talk a
little bit
about the response and how it's the
response to 911 and how it has differed
from the response to covet and we also
talked about
jersey city is home to a large muslim
population
and they have been the center of
controversy
as some people have uh drudged up old
allegations that
muslims cheered the uh attacks of 9 11
which
the mayor said is patently false and not
a shred of evidence that it is true and
yet those old suspicions have lingered
and in neighboring bayonne uh efforts by
the muslim community to build a mosque
had been blocked for many years before
they sued and the justice department
stepped in and
now the mosque can be built and so we
talked a little bit about
uh the challenges of um building bridges
and of running one of the nation's most
diverse cities
and frank in those conversations what
have been some of the
learnings that you've taken away from
these local officials about how to
handle
these big problems right we've got
coronavirus racial injustice there's a
lot going on so what have been
the biggest kind of lessons you've
learned from them well there's so much
going on
and i think in some ways mayors are
overwhelmed
because they're getting so little help
uh especially from the federal level but
all of these issues are local at heart
uh mayors are in charge of the covid
response they are the
uh they're held accountable for on
issues of racial injustice
and so they are really uh on the front
lines of all of these
uh the challenges and no easy answers
i had a great conversation with mayor
jaffer of montgomery township new jersey
she is the first
muslim woman to serve as mayor in the
united states
and she talked a little bit about this
group that she's created called
montgomery mosaic which is intended to
bridge build across communities and they
they gather in different houses of
worships
uh houses worship uh in different parts
of the community and talk about
some of these issues so she said that
when they've done it before
they get a group of you know maybe 100
people and she'll ask for a show of
hands how many of you have been in a
synagogue before how many of you been in
the mosque before
and uh she says that most of the hands
don't go up
uh and so even just that sense of place
and bringing people together uh
in places that are outside their comfort
zone uh
she said that has been uh helpful in
creating
some of these uh connections and holding
some of these difficult conversations
that i think people feel
inherently uncomfortable with and frank
what's next for you
on this journey i know you've got a lot
booked and and some of it is gonna kind
of
run alongside your column here but if
you could just give us a little sneak
peek about what you're
most excited about for the week to come
well
we had we had a great trip through
pennsylvania and i'll be writing about
that this week
um starting in philadelphia where there
are
there's a homeless encampment just
outside the philadelphia museum of art
which is the rocky steps and
the city is struggling with how to deal
with that i
had a great conversation um with
um with a guy who was the leader of a
band
many people on this stream probably know
called volktoni
they become a little bit of a streaming
streaming sensation but his songs have
um songs focus on
the underdogs and uh have socially
conscious bent to some of them and so we
talked a little bit about
uh what you know what what drives those
songs and
people's need for for music during all
of this uh
turmoil and sense of crisis so it's a
it's a little bit
uh tangential but i think still really
important so we're gonna be trying to
cover some of those
uh issues that uh or or aspects of life
that may not
be in the news every day but that i do
think are important to the way people
relate to
the way that they are experiencing life
and their communities
uh you've got a lot of ground to cover
frank so we don't take too much of your
time because you've got to get all the
way to san francisco
um but i'll remind our viewers that we
will be checking in with you every week
but before we let you go i just want to
know what it's been like in this tiny rv
with you and your wife as you're both
um working from home on the road it's
been
great actually we've taken to it and i
mean maybe we came because we came from
a one-bedroom city apartment and are
used to
being in tight quarters it hasn't been
that much of an adjustment but
it's been really good we've been
learning all the ins and outs of an rv
which
there's more to it than i realized and
we've screwed some things up and
uh had some trouble getting things to
work but for the most part
uh it's been going really well and i
read in your
con that was posted this morning and
that you had some challenges finding
parking and with your refrigerator would
have been the biggest
uh obstacle that you hadn't necessarily
anticipated
well parking's definitely been an
obstacle uh and we
look at how it goes through the hearts
of towns and
big cities so um i had a friend from
philadelphia email me after the columbra
and said i can't believe you drove into
south philly with an rv
but that's where the highway goes so
that's where we're going and uh we've
scraped a few trees along the way and
overhanging branches
uh but we've managed to come out of it
and
we'll see how it goes from here and
frank one final question for the viewers
who are just
joining our stream here what's your main
goal for this trip what are
what are you hoping to get out of this
we're hoping to
um get to listen and to give people
an opportunity to say what's important
to them
and in doing that to i hope draw out of
them
a little bit about what they believe is
important to the future of the country
and what binds us together as a nation
when we're in the midst of all of this
division
and i think there's tons of focus on it
rightfully so politically culturally
racially we are there's a lot of
deep divisions that are challenging but
we also want to
learn a little bit more about ourselves
and the sense of what is it that holds
us together
and so along the route we've been asking
people that that question and
um getting some interesting answers and
it'll be interesting by the end of it to
see where there's some overlap and
see what the more creative and outlying
ideas are
well we are very excited to get to check
in with you here every monday
and hear what you're learning from the
road and kind of experience this journey
alongside you so thank you for making
the time frank uh and for those of you
watching please
come back every monday uh and follow
frank's journey along with us here
um you can follow bloomberg quick take
for all of your news on all social
platforms and thank you so much for
joining us
thanks